we may not ever know what charles's
actual inheritance is for the simple
reason that the queen's will
will remain confidential
knowing how much the queen adored her
grandchildren and her
great-grandchildren i'm sure that
accommodations have been made for all of
them in her world including harry and
meghan and archie and lilly bert i mean
one of the queen's great regrets was
that she didn't get to see more of
archie and lily but but i'm sure pieces
of jewelry special mementos will
absolutely have been reserved for those
great grandchildren too so what's going
to happen to the royal estates well the
two properties that the queen did own
are balmoral and sandringham both
estates handed to her from her father
king george vi of course balmoral was
where the queen died it was one of her
favorite residences she used to spend
every summer there charles has a
scottish residence it's called burke
hall it's not far from balmoral and that
is his bolt hole and there has been talk
and speculation that he may open up
balmoral to the public in the way that
he has done with dunfry's house which is
also in scotland there's a possibility
he might do the same with highgrove his
own private residence where the gardens
are open to the public
sandringham he's turned into the most
wonderful example of organic farming
it's already open to the public prince
william has inherited
921 million dollars and and that of
course merges with the estate that he
inherited from his diana that's 17
million pounds from his late mother so
in his own right prince william is now a
very financially wealthy independent
young man so whereas he was supported by
his father in his official work he's now
got his own pot of gold to finance his
and his wife's official work he will now
be paying for his own official life we
are likely never going to know the the
details of the queen's will because it
will remain confidential but i'm sure
that something has been left whether
that is financial sentimental piece of
jewelry
from the queen to each of her children
her grandchildren and her
great-grandchildren and of course that
includes prince harry
[Music]
you